that's what I'm going to comradery and
socializing with people with similar
viewpoints things like that to learn
from each other and share everything I
think it's a really great place to
gather in to network and to share ideas
I'll I for a lot of things I haven't
heard before I'm here to learn really
Lenny ho what kind of libertarian I am I
was just looking forward to a weekend of
meeting good people fellow Oh Liberty
lovers students for liberty is a 501 C 3
run by students and for students
dedicated to Liberty it was just a
12-person roundtable discussion then it
was just a 30-person conference then it
was just a hundred person conference we
had 300 to students last year we know
the final count yet this year it'll be
about 500 I've never seen so many pro
Liberty students anywhere in my entire
life and at this conference to I've been
getting a unique impression of
libertarianism as a humanitarian
movements as well the reason I'm a
libertarian is because I believe it
helps the most people I think the old
sins of free markets in a free society
benefit you made the most I think that
most students are libertarian I think
that they just they aren't exposed to
these ideas and finally there's an
organization going out there and
exposing them to the philosophy of
Liberty along with hosting these
incredible conferences it's about trying
to figure out what students need and and
making sure we have it there for them
SFL definitely provides a variety of
resources providing people with
networking opportunities with people at
reason Cato all these groups IHS given a
lot of people I know and everyone here a
lot of free literature to read and
obviously I'm brand and all her books
need more people be connected with more
members of the Liberty movement as well
as become word on fire more inspired to
spread the message over Bernie favorite
part was one of the sessions today and
it was a networking one definitely been
the breakout sessions you get more
intimate more in-depth all these
students in a few years from now they're
all going to be leaders in our society
and however they want to affect Liberty
they're going to be doing something
about it we're just trying to get a
student group i'm here with my sister
and another front of my campus and want
to hopefully start at yale chapter maybe
hopefully idea is to bring back to my
school like my campus help hopefully to
help kind of grow that group a little
more I wanted to take back the ideas i
got from here see how they apply to my
country I'm from Nigeria I'll take my
stand I'll begin I'll do what I can do
if I can reach to people that will be
fine really hope to advance Liberty in
my lifetime we're having a really great
moment right now and it's really gonna
be up to us to make it so it's not just
a moment but more a cultural shift I see
the libertarian movement getting larger
we're going to reach out to more
students or get more alumni involved and
it's just growing every day